i was on the day out in brighton uh for
my friend's birthday and took a photo
then the next day one of my followers
just said like john cena but then they
got to a point where all these people
were just liking them just screaming oh
my god that's a natural scene what the
hell then just got really really really
big meet brendan cabina john cena's
doppelganger who has the whole internet
doing a double take after posting this
snap to social media earlier this month
wild right it's pretty flattering when
people do say it because you know
cena was a handsome individual well it
gets even more wild because the snap
went viral and even john cena himself
posted the pic to his own instagram page
i've had like people like tell me oh my
god you need to become famous
like you literally look like a black
jozini and i always sort of brushed it
off so when this happened i was kind of
like oh
it's actually gone viral that's
pretty insane now everyone's saying it
rather than just
my group of friends or a few strangers
here and there now the 24 year old's
uk-based bodybuilder is opening up to et
about the whole thing revealing this
isn't the first time people have pointed
out the resemblance the first time i
heard that i looked like john cena would
have been you know around 2008 when i
was like 13 14. then as i got older i
started to see a lot more it used to get
to a point where when i was like 15 or
16
when people say to me you look like
someone i don't know who it is
and then i'm like it's john cena and
then they lose it they're like yeah
that's it you look like john cena well
now everyone knows
and the fitness expert who runs his own
coaching business called omega muscles
says his newfound fame on social media
has impacted his life in a big way let's
help my fitness industry you know my
fitness business my fitness company and
me as a fitness person
get out there more has actually helped
me a lot you know it's changed my life
to the point where
you know
i'm a verified accountant on instagram
people recognize me i've had people on
the streets actually recognizing me as
well i've had
someone say hey you're the black singer
guy aren't you i'm like yeah yeah i'm
back to the guy and i was crazy i'm
happy with it you know it gives me a
chance to meet and interact with new
people but one person he hasn't
interacted with yet the real john cena
hey john you know your your brother's
here if you ever want to
uh have a chat and what's not let's
let's meet up someday you know brendan
even said he'd be down to take on john
in the ring i feel like i can handle him
you know not not in an arrogant way but
he's
someone who's you know similar height to
me i'm someone who's trained in the gym
for by a few years now uh so i've gotten
used to heavy weight and what's not i
think i'd be able to hand myself pretty
well you know
for now we'll just have to wait and see
if john and his look-alike ever meet irl
but until then brendan had this to say
to all of his new followers
i genuinely put him by my heart love you
all
i've been having a blast for the past
month i've seen all your messages
a lot of them are really nice it's given
me
a lot more motivation to be better in
what i do it's genuinely made me very
very happy so to all the fans i
genuinely love
and appreciate all of you so thank you
so much
[Music]
you